dan dan dan I'll secure bread
let's welcome to corpse party so this is
probably gonna be a long series and it's
probably gotta be a lot of books it's
gonna be a good times you and me baby I
know this is the kind of series that
maybe a lot of people won't miss out on
because there's gonna be a lot of text
and and story in the first episodes I
know that might make a lot of people go
into the second episode but still I
really hope that you stay with me on
this series I think it's gonna be a
great one I've been wanting to play this
game for so long I loved all the pixel
horror games and this is obviously one
of the most beloved ones so without
further ado I bring you Bruce corpse
party okay chapter one begin oh good
Sachi is my pride and joy mine -
actually I wrote that probably shed for
anything me what I really planted the
reading these I don't think I got a come
on
I guess Hebrews can pass but I still
love her with all my heart
well that's cute
touken ah I mean who didn't listen brain
evening after school just like this one
running down the stairs the kindly
teacher lost her footing she tumbled and
she fell and she died you've all heard
the stories know before Kisaragi Academy
was built here there was another school
on this heavenly hosts Elementary School
it was called such a horrible thing to
happen the principal was completely
devastated he cared for the school
almost as if it were his own child you
see but one thing led to another after
the incident and ultimately a decision
was reached the school was to be shut
down the principal was so striking with
the grief of losing his precious child
that on the day of its closure he
climbed up to the roof and threw himself
to his death or so the story goes
people thought heavenly host was cursed
you see this is just the latest of many
deaths to occur there that's why I was
torn now however they say the teacher
who fall down the stairs still has no
idea she's dead even to this very day
and on rainy evenings like this after
our school days come to mend some claim
she roams these dark in hallways still
believing them to be her own in fact
it's almost time for her to make her
rounds just after 7 o'clock that's when
she appears always accompanied by sudden
blackout that leaves the entire building
darkest night knock knock you'll hear
from the blackness followed by the sound
of the classroom door slowly slide her
pale white fades cuts through the
stillness her soft voice always echoes
the same question here's anyone still
here and then
haha that's totally me if something
happens like that actually that might be
more like me it's a black hat south of
sheep pull yourself together don't scare
us like that what it was scary I don't
like this that shouldn't be happening
dang I colder than us you know lucky oh
Jesus that was short not bad shinozaki
you had me going there for a minute it
wasn't me
I've been standing right here the whole
time this is a real blackout
hey naked oh my god I love her hair
so Cowie just anyone else you hear that
sounds like it's coming from the music
range okay I'd be freaking out
I'd be pooping my pants
no way first the blackout and now the
door is boys either she the hell is
wrong with you Satoshi get a hold of
yourself and get off of me that's my of
course that's totally so anime AK sorry
sorry I couldn't see where I was
grabbing of course I never see what I
grab either I told you it was a bad idea
to say it so late at Teleco sorry
oh hey Satoshi aren't you gonna get to
do what the girls are all trembling in
fear doesn't he just break your heart to
see them like lat Baghdad well it
doesn't break my balls it's mine I got
you so why don't you get the door when
you didn't make my heart that's cold man
so really I'm gonna do it no I don't
want to do it so we're really are sad
Toshi
that's awesome a pair of scared perverts
it's really me it's anyone still here
Oh children ah that's the teacher's name
did I scare you miss Yui dandy hey I
teach what I call that a rousing success
[Music]
the timing could have been more perfect
I wasn't standing here too long ago
myself so when it comes to the seven
wonders of Kisaragi hi I'm pretty well
versed love the music fantasy haha
I thought chicks reaction was priceless
but yours was a whole different level
altogether Machida almost huskily
it was pretty impressive I could never
hope to compete with a hmm where she
does always get the best reactions I
just love it when my scares are so
thoroughly effective it's simply
delicious for Satoshi hmm who ever heard
of class representative with such
sadistic streak anyway sorry about that
mushy dad but I can't deny your reaction
was pretty amusing Liam Liam
I'll practice ID though I ran into a
rather adorable individual in the hall
who's come to see you what are you
standing around out there for come in
come on in he's right there
he's right here I can't [ __ ] read
it's this Oh
Yuka what are you doing eating
oh it's seems mashita forgot his
umbrella this morning so little yogurt
has come all this way to delivery Wow
oh yeah I guess I did sorry about that
you can thanks
yeah she from jr. hi nice to meet you
my brother's always like this always
really kind I mean of course of course
sorry I had no idea you had such a cute
little sister Satoshi really I never
told you you never said a word
you sure do love your big brother don't
you oh my god it is adorable
sure we do ah hmm seems like she's met
kiss your new goddammit should she know
my before what you know me looks like
you got yourself a rival eh I'm sure I
don't know what you're talking about
I swear this map of your safety craziest
things what do they do it all right
everybody it's past 7:00 isn't it about
time y'all get ready for hub huh what
what is it now told you there'd be a lot
of text oh do we have to shouldn't we
clean up all the red beans cafe stuff
first it'd be a shame to leave so soon
yeah for the class room like this it
almost seems like we could hold another
culture festival to marry isn't that
what you were supposed to be doing here
in the first place you promised me this
room really ready to go by the time I
got here as I recall well it's getting
late
how about you leave it for now and come
in early tomorrow Susumu I know how hard
it is say goodbay but I wish you the
best of luck at your new school I know
you'll do just fine thanks oh poor
little girl it won't be the same around
here without you sue to me I had no uses
Amaro you'll make new friends in no time
flat I'm sure of it and it's not like
you're moving that far away Oh what come
winter break we'll all make sure we come
visit yeah totally
don't look so glum we'll see you again
real soon we're friends forever
you guys oh hey brother who's that girl
transferring to a new school or
something yeah today's culture festival
was our last day thank you so much oh
I'm so grateful to have you as friends
you have all a special place in my heart
oh hey Kara without death I'll always be
watching over here from above
it's Seiko over to Seco my spirit will
guide your path
you're not dead you know malya I do come
on let's see that smile of yours but how
about we get everybody in the shot are
they still a picture ah yeah I totally
wanted oh wow ready there already make
it yeah me three
me four that's adorable what is so cute
look how big boots their thesis I've
been to Japan they're not like that not
that I look okay this is weird I
shouldn't have okay big brother
hmm hmm your friends are really great
you know they share
[Music]
gimme gimme I want to see send it to my
phone would you Marie she okay of course
I'll send it to all of you right now hey
teach before we head back there's
something I'd like to do with everyone
what is going on in like this okay
mm-hmm what the hell is this
since we're losing one of our own do you
mind if we try it
it's called Sachiko ever after who's
Sachiko and what's for the paper doll
is this another one of your occult
things what she has a cold things what
about him
yeah kind of this is well it's a charm
that I found on the Internet oh god that
can't be gay oh god this is gonna be a
real big if you do it right then all of
us will be together forever or we'll
always be friends anyway
that's the gist of it I don't like the
gist it's a chore yeah I mystical charm
authsub I taught me what I do it
I think Tina Zaki had her at charm I
can't let's totally bunker for that kind
of stuff yes it can't hurt it will hurt
everyone okay with this hi you big buddy
yeah you too oh yes
I don't like this Prez Oh God what are
they doing with that doll
it looks really awkward everybody
gathering a circle around this paper
Sachiko doll and in your head repeat the
words Sachiko
we beg of you seven eight nine
yeah repeated nine times don't worry if
you flub it alone just make sure you
don't stop part way through you have to
say it one time for every person present
no more no less
or the charm will fail what happens if
it fails exactly yeah it does seem very
sketchy it looks like I I don't want to
say it but you know what I'm thinking
it's all paper don't think seems a
little sketchy to me failure is not an
option just give it all you've got
okay okay I don't like this Rose I don't
like it one bit
alright let's get started everybody to
remember the charm I don't [ __ ] Sachiko
we beg of you nine times right
Sachiko good everybody said it nine
times yeah yeah if we don't get on with
it I'm afraid I'll wind up saying it
again
this is so creepy why would anyone do it
is [ __ ] okay now everybody reach towards
a paper doll and grab hold of it
anywhere you can she doesn't fit got it
I think oh okay so that's how I did okay
like this so everyone has to get a piece
is that it exactly now hold on really
tight dig your nails into it if you have
to just don't let go we're going to pull
on it until it rips apart into nine
pieces okay on the count of three one
two three I really hope everyone gets
Oh for Satoshi yack
nicely done everyone now let now just
make sure you keep that scrap of paper
safe slide it into your student ID
holder or your wallet basically anywhere
it won't get lost
hmm so the pitied your grip has easy
meaning do it
yep as long as we all have a little
piece of Sachiko with us we'll always be
connected with one another as friends
that's the purpose of this charm wow
that's actually pretty cool pretty cool
try super cool I'll have to be extra
careful not to lose my piece
Jesus's entry is it long as inter ever
Thank You Chi nozaki I'll treasure this
no problem consider our promise that
we'll all definitely hang out together
again definitely well I hate to say it
but I think it's about time we all get
packed up and start heading home yeah
dad yeah an earthquake uh-oh what is
happening
they kinda LOI finally but the hell this
is like holy crap big Oh God
oh [ __ ] what's going on we're all gonna
die hold close yo gotta go through
you're gonna take my hand my god this is
like a Michael Bay movie
everybody's sick huh get under your desk
until it passes
oh [ __ ] out of the desk now what oh god
what no this can't be happening is this
for real
scepter she move move sector she AK Adam
filing No such a shame
oh god what just happened that's pretty
interesting encho even though it lasted
forever at least you know all the
background a little character and all
the stuff that's what it's for right I
think so
I'm sorry breast but I think that'll
have to do it for today it's pretty
interesting so far I really really hope
you joined me on this I think it's gonna
be a great series it's a great game
after all and that's what I everyone
keeps saying at least so please leave a
like if you enjoy watching I really
appreciate it especially especially
games like this cuz I know it's all I
know a lot of people will love it and I
know a lot some people won't so I would
love to see the people loving it show it
show the support so thank you for doing
that and I'll see you tomorrow with the
new one so stay awesome bros love you
[Music]